jack richie was 24 when he wrote an
email to his parents saying he was past
the point of controlling himself he felt
the only way out of his gambling
addiction was to take his own life
an inquest into his death at sheffield
town hall concluded that whilst suicide
is always complex it was abundantly
clear that gambling contributed to
jack's death this is the first inquest
of its kind to examine the link between
suicide and gambling and the way it's
regulated and it found that information
warnings and treatment was all woefully
inadequate at the time of jack's death
and more needs to be done to prevent
future suicides
jack's parents in court every day for
this two-week inquest say now is time
for the government to act
they're a parasitic industry and we've
haven't had a government that was asleep
at the wheel
they have been collusive
with these parasites the rulings really
today are seismic they are a recognition
of the failures of government and the
dangers of gambling it's very clearly
accepted there's a really strong link
which has been known for decades about
the relationship between gambling and
suicide jack's gambling started when he
won big aged 17 on a fixed odds betting
machine but his luck would run out as he
turned to online gambling
campaigner and former gambling addict
matt saab cousin says regulators haven't
kept up with the industry
on online slots there's no limit to the
stakes on online roulette there's no
limit to the stakes there's no proper
affordability checks
so we've basically put a casino in
everyone's pocket and i think that the
the regulatory framework is clearly not
fit for purpose i mean it's not taking
into account that there is a risk to
life
for people who engage with gambling
uh it's promoting it as if it's you know
like a fun fair or something it's
there's something much more sinister
going on the industry says it's
committing more money to help with
addiction and regulators the gambling
commission told sky news since jack's
death in 2017 we have accelerated our
drive to make gambling safer this has
included increased enforcement and
compliance activity clamp down on online
slots products increased online age and
id verification and brought in new rules
to stamp out irresponsible vip customer
practices
isn't charles ritchie say much more as
needed the coroner agrees and has sent a
report to the government setting out how
to prevent deaths like jax which will
inform a review into gambling laws
expected to come out this spring jason
farrell sky news